how many would like to be financially
free I'm gonna give you some practical
steps to achieve that and then we're
gonna go and do it this weekend through
property how many of you have come here
to learn about HMOs no money deals lease
option agreement sourcing properties for
yourself joint ventures below market
value
our team tips if we kind of cover that
would it be worthwhile program yes so
here's what's gonna happen right now you
guys we're role-playing we're doing the
practicals we'll get in on the Internet
we're finding the properties we're
working out the percentages we're
working out the returns on investment to
see if it is a good deal we're phone in
the estate agents it's not very it's not
just sitting there writing it it's not
about that it's about practically doing
it to make sure when you leave you know
what you're doing and you can do it I
want to make this as valuable as
worthwhile and as fruitful as I possibly
can I think what Sanders has actually
taught me is that there there is another
way of actually making yourself
financially free which is basically his
personal development and investment in
self this is the guy I want to learn
from because he has a warm heart and
he's very good and he is a giver he
wants to make a difference in the world
I'm living the same dream as face so it
was great to connect with him this
weekend I'm very grateful I took the
step to fly over and be with this
amazing guy on the count of three one
two three
you